before i was an avenger i made
mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies last time we spoke
was at the avengers endgame junket and i
asked you about black widow and you said
until i'm at crafty eating turkey cold
cuts like i'm not gonna this isn't
happening yet
so it's crazy we're like here now
yeah it's it is crazy uh you know
it's also i mean i still feel that way
i'm like
until i am you know
on the set and first a d is screaming
action
um you know that first day i i just
never think something's gonna
ever come to fruition i think that's
just part of being an actor for hire
is that you just are always sort of like
do i have a job or
not sure um it's like ingrained in all
of us and
uh yeah i'm still kind of pitching
myself that this movie
is actually really now finally coming
out well we're all pinching ourselves
it's incredible by the way so
congratulations to both of you my first
question
is for you scarlett you know obviously
you're reprising
this character and i think a question
that pops into a lot of people's heads
is how do you go back to this version of
natasha
you know what was it a what was
important for you to bring to the
surface about her
and like what new versions of her were
you excited to explore
you know it was a really unique
experience of working
backwards because when we were shooting
end game
uh you know we knew obviously what her
ultimate
sacrifice would be um and
wanted to make sure that that felt like
a choice
um and came with peace for her
and uh that she was okay with you know
she says that to
to clinch she says you know it's okay
and she means that
she means it uh she you know it had she
had to have had
a a you know she had to have reconciled
something within herself and so we knew
that this was the opportunity to
make that happen so while we knew okay
at the end of this film there has to be
self-forgiveness so that she can move on
to to that place
and um yeah and then it was really
just kind of chipping away and finding
the best way to tell that story
um you know and make it dynamic
and of course what better way to do that
than
with a poking and prodding younger
sister
character who's like oh you don't want
to look backwards
here it is here's your mess like you
have to face it
you know and she drags nat kicking and
screaming through that process
wild yeah well speaking of your
character florence i think you guys
definitely found the best way to tell
that story by the way but
florence this is your character's first
introduction into the mcu
are you still geeking out a little bit
like how do you feel like how
experienced for you totally i mean we
made the movie
two years ago now um it was
crazy that i even got the job and then
crazy that i was even on set and then
crazy that we even rapped
um and then you know we were about to
release the film and then
um the pandemic happened and so there
was just there's just been a lot of like
this uh stop start is this real
or is this surreal um and i feel
really excited now to show people what
we made two years ago
um because you know i watched the movie
uh the last week and um
even though it was on my laptop and my
laptop doesn't go very loud i was just
so impressed and so excited and so
like i was so happy that i loved the
film
and i would have loved the film whether
i was going to the cinema and i had
nothing to do with it like i was just so
proud of it
um and the fact that this is my first
you know
here i am uh welcome to the mcu i i was
just
uh so amazed with with all the work that
we put in
and and just how enjoyable it was to
watch it makes me happy to hear you say
that you're so proud of it even on a
small screen i can't wait for you to see
it on a big screen because i was so
proud you know as a woman watching it
hearing you guys have conversations
about reproduction
even the little jokes that you guys made
to each other about the vest
i was like this is a conversation i
would have with my friend in a car
it honestly to see it in an mcu film was
like
mind blown how does it feel to you guys
to be a part of this project because
this is the most
female-centered mcu movie i think i've
ever seen yeah i mean that was
you know that was our goal when we
really looked at okay what do we
all right we don't we don't have to tell
this story we're
we're telling it because we want to okay
so that's really liberating it's
daunting in some ways but it gives you
all this free reign and it would be we'd
be amiss if we didn't
reflect on what's happening in the
zeitgeist
and and um you know how
empowering it is for women to be lifting
each other up out of
a situation and and um you know and
strengthening one another
and supporting one another i mean
there's definitely another version of
this
that would be the you know movie that we
probably would have made 10 years ago
which is like
you know two women facing off to gain
power
and you know that's not how women
react to one another or relate to one
another how much more interesting is
this story
um you know to really see uh
women coming out the other side as
survivors from some shared traumatic
experience
that you know they they both or they all
have
you know have had to face and uh and
something that's been holding them back
that they can now move forward
from like that's just incredible you
know that we were able to
um be in a place where the studio would
support that message
you know it's it's it's been a long
journey to get here and it's exciting to
know that that's
that we will we're never going to be
looking backwards it's just going to be
moving forward
i i was just gazing at her and nodding
the entire way through yeah exactly
like um i don't know i think my
from my perspective coming on board
something
this um bold but also this female
is such a luxury that it's kind of going
hand in hand with it then being a
massive
movie that lots of women and men will go
and watch
um and you know it tackles
so many subjects and in such a
a wonderful way where you really can't
look away from it and you have to listen
and it's all you can it's all
information that you can swallow and you
can digest and you can also
enjoy this movie about family and about
these two sisters
um so yeah i'm just i'm just incredibly
grateful that
uh kate shortland directed it that
scarlett is obviously
at the lead and produced it um
and we really had so many amazing women
on set
also guiding this film into the right
direction
um and so even though it's obviously
really cool
it's a big marvel superhero film i think
if you took that away
it would still be just as impressive um
and that's that's really exciting you're
going to get the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair congratulations
on the film you know you're a father
figure in this film you're also a father
to
11. so i'm curious what draws you to
these types of rules and
are you the best dad in hollywood
uh answer the second question no
uh answer the first question um
they you know i don't know if i'm drawn
to the roles or the roles are drawn to
me
or whatever it is uh in this world this
weird kismet coincidence world where
you know and i mean the really
interesting thing is i've recently
become like a step dad in my real life
and people are always like oh did that
help you with the part and i'm like
actually the part sort of helped me with
that
like a lot of times i feel like
you know when you're ready for something
emotionally the part kind of comes to
you to
prepare you to play it in life or or
life prepares you to play the part
i do i do find that that has been the
case for me i mean i've been
circling around commitment and family in
my life and being very fearful of it a
lot in my life
and then now i've been circling around
and finally have landed myself in a
situation and it's only been
i think as a result of tapping into a
lot of these things
that stranger things and this thing you
know
pla how it affects me uh in my life when
i played
i love it you know as someone who's like
close with her dad i i feel like you're
coming for tom hanks
because i i watch you and i'm like
you're
you're such a dad i don't know if you
want to have kids of your own one day
but
you're such a dad oh thank you that's
very nice of you
it's very sweet yeah in the best way
possible um what's super fun about
watching you
in this film is you play you know the
russian captain america
was it fun for you to play that
disgruntled cap
yeah absolutely i mean one of the things
i love about him
is so often you know you have this
character red guard and you know he's
kind of a counterpart captain america
and you've seen all these movies like
iron man's like we watched tony stark
like become iron man
find this thing inside him that is
beautiful and heroic
and captain america is this you know
scrawny guy and he gets this thing and
he becomes
and like we skip all of that in this
movie and we start with like him just at
the end of his
rope and just red guardians past his
prime he's like
out of shape not you know a mess like
emotionally just angry resentful uh full
of remorse
and i like love that you know that
that's one of the things that makes him
and he sort of starts on
his journey to redemption from there uh
to sort of
re invest in this family and the choices
that he made and try to figure out what
his life
has become and why it's become what it's
become um so
yeah that was what was really drew me to
the character was just how
you know amazingly three-dimensional he
was and he's a guy you know
this guy who has like crazy tattoos and
there's like rough and tumble and also
he like wants people to laugh at his
jokes
like really you know sort of sweet and
like so those sorts of complexities i
feel like drew me to him and he's like
yeah he's just an incredible he's an
incredible guy like i love him i don't
know if
you know people have mixed will have
mixed feelings about him but i i really
love him i disagree he's like my new
favorite like marvel okay
like i think everyone's gonna be
obsessed we'll see
it's
i wanted to ask you you know because you
you bring up a good point
that we start at like the end of his
journey did you build his back story at
all
and what is your version of his
backstory because of course you know we
can look to the comics but what was your
version what did you build for him
i mean the great thing about it is you
know and some people ask they're like
what are the actual events with him and
captain america did you ask the marvel
guys like what it was
and i was like no because the great
thing about red guardian is he lives at
his own fantasy universe so whether or
not any of this is real he believes it's
real
fully that he fought these battles and
he did these heroic thing
so whether or not i mean it's kind of
great if none of it's real just
his confabulatory mind has created this
reality
um so that was really important to
figure out that as he sits in prison
he's come up with all these
justifications for his life
and what he had done and that that was
all rich and then
the real important thing to figure out
backstory wise was the prelude to the
movie
in terms of what their lives were like
um when they were younger and they were
in this constructed
ruse that molina calls it of young
natasha young
molena and me molina and
you know there were things that came out
of that i don't know what kind of
spoiler event we'll get here but there's
uh you know there's a certain
song that plays very heavily in the
movie and that all came out of this
exploration and rehearsal that we had
and we were like you know we'd sit
around the four of us and go like what
would they listen to
like you know maybe elena did have a
favorite tape that she always wanted
daddy to play in the car
i mean there were all these sort of
speculations based on our own personal
things that we would yeah and so though
that was where the true beauty was and
that was where the connection of four of
us came from was like
you know i could say to florence like
what did your dad you know do and
then we could play on that together or
like rachel myself and that's where the
richness of the connections came from
from us doing that rehearsal and then us
bringing it to the film
wow that's so crazy you say that because
i grew up in the 90s and i don't want to
spoil the song but it is a song that
like your dad
teaches you i learned you know that song
from my father
um i had to ask you about this suit you
know did it fit was it made to be
uncomfortable
what was the suit like oh it's made to
fit
i mean the funny thing about these suits
is like it they
they print out a 3d model of your body
and then they flash in the zoom which is
by the way disgusting and terrifying
that somewhere there's still a 3d
printed model of my
at my worst 275 pound david harbor
sitting somewhere in a closet just like
uh and then they
you know they sculpted to that thing and
then of course like on the day that we
do the scene in the bathroom
they really launder it freshly laundered
like those jeans that just came out of
the dryer so it's quite tight
and the scene there's not much acting
involved just the physics of trying to
get it over your love handles
it's very you know easy to play
but yeah they sculpt it right to your
body it's very and it's
really enjoyable to move it's really
enjoyable to wear it is an enjoy
if i could just wear that for the rest
of my life and not have to choose my
clothing i'd be down
i'd be down to just walk around with
that floor listen let's get you back in
there i mean do you think we're gonna
get to see
red guardian again can you pitch us his
disney plus series
i mean i hope so i'll tell you what i'm
i'm ready i mean
you know tweet your local disney
representative
at kevin feige whatever and let them
know how you feel
um yeah i uh i love this character i
would love there's so many things you
could do with him
too there's so many worlds he can exist
in and so we'll see
you know we'll see what's if there's
something next i hope something
yeah i'd love to ponder on that you know
it's funny when you look at like all the
stuff going on in your life and the
characters that you've been bringing to
screen as of late i feel like russians
are just this recurring theme you know
does hover ever meet red guardian in
russian prison
have you thought of this i know they i
that would be you know god that would be
that would have been a great idea
i should talk i still got a little more
filming maybe maybe i could talk to the
duffer brothers about then we should put
an easter egg
that would be a
a special thanks um yeah no it's a
really
wild coincidence that i round up in two
russian prisons
and i think you know i've talked about
it too it's like i had the beard and
long hair and i was prepared to play
sort of like you know the next season we
were gonna and then this came up and
i was like oh i'm definitely using the
beard and the whole thing it's gonna be
great and marvel was like yeah okay
that's we didn't really but okay that
sounds great
and i and then when stranger things
rolled around i was like
we can't have it be the same look guys
it's a russian prison so we came up with
a whole backstory for that
that on the fly and i mean they're very
good at that duffer brothers are very
into using what they have improving
based on
and they their ideas get even better as
a result of that so
you know a lot of the look that you see
of this shaved head and the whole thing
was
we we came up with kind of a different
prison based on that and i
i think it made it so much better so
sometimes these things that are again
these things that are creative
impediments or whatever become
actual like gifts anything you can tell
us about stranger things for we're
the whole world's obviously so stoked
for it yeah oh good i'm glad to hear
they're still stoked i'm sorry that it's
taking so long
i mean i feel bad personally i want to
apologize to every single one of you
damn
stranger things fans uh it's just
really good and that takes time but
you're gonna love this season
it's extraordinary hopper is
better than ever and uh yeah i can't
wait for you to see him
i'm sorry we had our orders and we
played the rules it wasn't real
rachel you were so exceptional in this
film as you are in everything you do i
it was such a pleasure watching you like
in an mcu movie it was really cool and
um
i know you've wanted or you've been a
fan of kate shortland
for a long time the director so i wanted
to know
why did she draw you to this role and
what was it like working with her
well i'd seen her felt had three her
three movies um
somersaults and laura and um
i'm just blanking on the name of the
berlin syndrome and
i i wanted to work with her for years so
marvel and and and scarlett are so
genius to invite ask someone like kate
to
to to tell the story of um
two sisters a mother figure
it's a very emotional story in all
kate's films have really been around
um young women um
in jeopardy finding themselves uh she's
those are the stories she's always told
so it was really brilliant to ask her to
to tell the story with three
female leads um yeah i was i was so
thrilled to be invited to do this
and so what was it like when you finally
got to work with her
kate is um just so
compassionate and warm that really knows
what she wants and she listens to
everybody on the set
hears everybody's point of view she
never she's never grumpy or loses her
temperature i mean
to steer such a massive ship like
like the black widow film i mean i can't
imagine how stressful it is but she was
so calm
and the the whole crew just loved her
and i and
and the actors are just we were kind of
in heaven with her because she's
she's a real access director so yeah it
was it was a great experience
oh you can tell i feel like all the
chemistry of the whole family all of you
guys it just
like shines and i'm sure that's a big
testament to kate this for me was one of
the most
i feel like one of the most female
focused marvel films that we've
ever seen um so it meant a lot to me to
watch it what did it mean to you to be a
part of it
i love telling stories about women i
guess because i am one
and i love i've got really great female
friends in my life and yeah i love
acting opposite women i've you know
most of my career up until recently i've
really acted
opposite men which is really great too
but it's lovely now to be telling
uh stories about women um
in uh yeah and in this in this really
unusual way because this is a you know
great big spectacular marvel action
movie with
you know big superhero set pieces but
at the heart of it it's yeah it's about
you know women
coming into their own coming to their
own power finding their family
yeah there's a lot of very emotional
emotional things at the heart of it
ah i love that um i also
wanted to just dive deep into molina
because she's just such a badass
character and i'm curious as to what
backstory you built for her
yeah i mean she she was trained as a
black widow
um i think she was plucked from her
mother i think she like a single mom i
always imagined that she had and
she was plucked by draco when she was
probably eight years old so
the red room is all she's known uh and
her life as a black widow is all she's
known i don't think she's really thought
much outside of it but
i think she's had enough of it and she's
retired to the
russian countryside uh to be a pig
farmer
which is not your uh stereotypical thing
to do
um so she's yeah she's a scientist and
the pigs are involved in a
secret thing that i i can't talk about
otherwise i have to marble jail
yeah so yeah she's um i think she's been
through
a lot of pain but she's very tough very
strong but
there's a there's a big beating heart
ready to thaw
underneath underneath i love that and
watching this film too you
it almost feels like a bond spy film
so i wanted to know you know did your
husband daniel craig did you lean on him
for anything do you feel like you're a
better spy than he is
i mean gosh this i mean we filmed them
at the same time actually in the same
studio at pinewood but they're such
different uh franchises
because you know the marvel
uh characters are say it it is a
brilliantly mythological universe it's
not something that
really exists whereas the the bond
universe
is rooted in as as uh exciting as it is
it's it's
it's like a it's more uh
human beings don't have any superpowers
i guess it's the simplest ways but it's
just it's just real life but a little
more exciting
did you guys bounce ideas off each other
since you were filming at the same time
you know what we we really don't talk
about our work to each other we like
just kind of try and do we don't talk
shop i guess it's the easiest thing to
wait to explain it yeah we just uh keep
our work
okay you private a plan or shall i just
stay dug and go my plan was to drive us
away
glorious plan sucks hi ot how are you
guys what's going on i'm so glad you
were that jacket
thank you so much i'm in life right you
have to wear things that make you smile
but speaking of
giving you life i'm sure this role was
life-changing in some way i mean landing
landing a role in an mcu movie is just
like so cool
what was the moment that you realized
you were in
an mcu movie um gosh i mean
when when they signed the contract and
then i was like well then now i'm in an
mcu movie aren't i
but also you know i mean every stage of
it is it was
wondrous you know doing the audition
going to
comic-con for the first time rehearsing
with with
um with the cast florence and scarlett
each moment was like whoa this is you
know a bit surreal
was there a specific moment on set that
you realized
wow this this is like a big deal well to
be honest most of the time i spend
my time trying not to make it a big deal
because i don't work well under that
kind of impression as if i'm honest
so i just had to tell myself aha just
another day of work ah
this scholar again
that's incredible it's so true that that
probably is very helpful
you know your character's so cool and
interesting
the whole when you're watching you're
sort of wondering what the back story is
there
so i was wondering if you could tell us
the back story that you created for
mason
well listen i can't go into all of it
but but they're definitely i mean
mason is ex-military he's got an
experience he's
he he probably you know works the
highest bidder and is probably a bit
disaffected and and feels
maybe a bit cynical about the world
powers and the way they
all work and that's why he's ready to
work for the highest bidder the only
difference is
i think with natasha it's not just about
money he's not just a mercenary in this
instance he's got a connection he has a
soft spot they have a history together
and
i think that's one of the interesting
thing that plays out in the subtext
between them
right it's just i i mean obviously i
don't want you to spoil anything but the
whole time i was like
were they romantically involved in a
previous life
i mean i mean you know i can't i can't
talk too much about
what we decided you know because who
knows what might happen in future movies
but there's definitely more than meets
the eye i think between them
okay and then as far as kate and the
direction that you got for the character
i was speaking to her earlier and she
was saying that she
writes back stories for all the
characters did you get that from her or
did you make it
under make it like yourself well we
didn't get it in written form but you
know her
and scarlett and i did sit down in
rehearsals and we talked through you
know what kate had figured what
i thought what my what you know
scarlett's intuitions were and we
created this
idea this vision about what their what
their past was
right well your character sort of
reminds me of
q from the bond films i was wondering if
that was an inspiration for you yeah
q but with more flirting is uh you know
because q never flirts with bond which i
think is a bit of a missed opportunity
seeing how cool
is that yeah it is that is true
would you want your character to be the
cue for avengers now that tony stark is
gone
um well listen somebody has to hook them
up with their
their gadgets so um you know i'm
available at the right price
at the right price do you think that
we'll see your character again
yeah i i think there's a great space for
mason i think he's a really fun
character and and
has a utility within the stories and
stuff like that so
i'd certainly love to do more i had such
a good time working
with you know marvel and disney on the
project so
yeah we'll see if he gets another outing
if he does get another
outing and you did want to see him come
back how would you like to see him come
back
in what capacity well you know i i think
i think he's really fun i'd like to see
him go on some missions you know that
kind of like
mission impossible thing when you've got
your tech techie guy with you i think
he's a lot of fun so
i think uh there's there's potential for
something like that
yeah i would love i think a lot of
people are gonna feel the same way after
they see this film
a lot of your scenes are with scarlett
johansson what was it like
filming and shooting with her um well
you know she's she's really fun
she's really mischievous in some ways
you know a mischievous sense of humor
she's she's really spontaneous and she's
really charismatic i mean gosh
it's you know it's a lot some point we
all have to choose
[Music]
between what the world wants you to be
and who you are
i wanted to know what it was like
working with scarlet and florence
because
their chemistry and sisterhood on screen
is one of the best parts
of this movie it was a joy working with
them
um i don't know we shot the first thing
they shot together i think was the fight
in the apartment
and they shot that for two weeks on and
off
so they got to know each other so well
and they really had to
work together they were always um
having fun together do you do anything
on set
to sort of create that sisterly bond
when it comes to like direction
we did four days of rehearsals
and i did back stories for all the
characters that they could read
and that went into their childhood and
their relationships kids
so they knew they knew that they'd had
an amazing bond as children
as well and that that what had happened
you know that they'd been ripped apart
wow that's so interesting normally when
you talk to actors i feel like they have
to create that backstory so i think
that's really cool that you did that
i think if they want it they could ask
me
if they didn't want it they didn't oh
that wasn't useful
yeah i love that well you know this is
one of the most female
focused marvel films i think that i have
ever seen
so what did it mean to you to be a part
of something like this
it was i think it was
kind of life-changing to be a part of
this
um it certainly made me
more appreciative of
what i do i think in before i might have
taken it for granted
and i think now i don't know it's such a
gift
doing a film like this because it's so
incredibly hard
but you feel like you're making a
difference
and i think that's pretty awesome
i love that answer but you know you make
a difference in like all your films
because i feel like in all your films
you
i was talking to rachel about this
earlier actually you oh
they're always about these strong female
characters
what was it like you know going from
directing those films
to now being a director in the marvel
cinematic universe
like can you paint the picture of like
what the difference is
the biggest difference is when you make
an indie film you've got 20 or 30 people
on set
and when we were doing our big scenes
we'd have three
to 400 people on set so
it's kind of it's kind of forgetting
what the
that big structure is and you just have
to walk in
and you feel thankful that all those
people are working
with you but what you have to do is kind
of
not think about them and just focus on
the actors or just
focus on that quarter second of that
kick
or the you know the half second of the
twirl or
you know you can't focus on the big
picture
you have to focus entirely on the
details
it's like life you just have to be
present you know but it's so hard when
everything's going on
let's talk about those kicks and stuff
because this film is so badass there's
so many incredible action sequences do
you have a favorite
i really love i love two fights in
particular i love
the fight between the girls and i love
the taskmaster fight with scarlet
because
we talked about that as a girl walking
to a train station and she gets attacked
you know it it was it had to feel that
she was
finding someone who she couldn't get the
upper hand
and that it had stakes and
yeah i really i really like it and i
love all the fire in it and
just the beauty of it yeah oh it's such
a beautiful film i love that you brought
up task master and i love the way
that taskmaster is used in the film
obviously without spoiling anything but
can you give us any insight into
you know what was going on in your brain
as far as like how to utilize this
character for this film
i think taskmaster's natasha's psyche
wow so i think in a way
when we see them together it's like
her doppelganger like it's the shadow
side of her
and i think what she learns during the
film is she has to love the shadow side
and that includes taskmaster and it
includes all the action
she's taken and all the bad things she's
done
she has to forgive herself i love that
where did that
idea or notion come from did that just
like come to you one day did it come
from like doing research on like the
comic book version
uh i think it just comes from thinking
about trauma
and how we exist and coexist with it in
our bodies and our minds and how we have
to make room for it
and um and sometimes beautiful things
can flower out of ugliness
oh so beautiful i love it another thing
i really really loved in the film
was the music he is amazing i love him
so much
yes lawn belf yes oh i i
waited for that name to pop up when the
credits were up because i'm like this is
incredible tell us about how you set the
tone
you know with him and and worked on
setting the tone for this film through
music
um i sent him a couple of pieces of
music
one is called dido's lament
and it's got the lyrics in it returned
to me
and it was really about
natasha and her soul
and then he took that
and he recreated um the melody and he
threaded that through
and then he took russian composers
and worked with um russian a russian
choir
in london and he and i had a ball
together
um and we were never really in the same
country
so he got on so well with the editors
and i
because um and the music
editor robbie it was one of the most fun
parts of the film
was was doing that beautiful music
ah it's so nice but he said it had to
have
it had to have her story and it had to
have her soul
and i thought that was so beautiful yeah
and you can feel her entire
soul through the film right like that so
and it's this beautiful thing
because we know you know we no longer
have natasha in the world we live in now
so i love that you guys brought that to
light when you're watching this movie
it feels like it's it's like a bond spy
mcu film was that your inspiration at
all when
when you came to this project i
was really my inspiration you know what
i looked at funnily enough i looked at
things like
um uh
no country for old men
uh thelma and louise
um a skywalk
sky what's it called the bond film
um skyfall skyfall
but really i also looked at stuff
where we were d women were dealing with
um
trauma trauma wow yeah and how do you
put yourself back together
and yeah i think thurman louise is great
for that because those women are
so funny but they've been through so
much
i'm done running
[Music]
oh
you